I love having French people in the show
that's very exciting French love
beautiful beautiful language and
beautiful country Shame about the people
what what are your what are your
professions do you have spe like
particularly French professions so she's
French I'm not French she's French
you're not French you just dress like a
Frenchman you look like David gter 20
years
ago really like if I looked at the two
of you I mean actually I would think you
you both just look so French what um so
my French lady what do you what do you
do I'm a nurse you're a nurse what's
nurse in French
nurse an Fier why are you so [__] why
so
difficult I need a nurse he's saved she
got here
quickly he's dead that was took too
long what so like you know over here the
ambulances are lying what's a French amb
[Music]
why is the abent stopped we are
smoking so you're a French nurse that's
pretty cool what's your favorite uh like
injury to kind of fix what do you like
when it comes in you're like oh I'm good
at
this um I don't know High surgery ey
surgery that is a weird answer is it
[Music]
uh [__] oh M I'm so
proud leier surgery that's very specific
that's very I'm sound in Fr very
specific that's so specific though does
everyone else think you're a bit weird
that like they come in like he's
rupturing his eyeball
ah why you licking your fingers that's
unsanitary unsanitary infir um my
[__] Jack BR this is great that's
great so when you were growing up where
did you grow up which which bit where
are you up yeah which bit of friends
bord Bordeaux oh my God that's great
that so did you want to become a
Vineyard owner a Vintner what did you
want to be when you were little uh no no
not that just nurse just nurse the whole
way through were you just a very very
serious
child I would be a
nurse
you're sick so
what all French women smoke it is it is
wild also you always take your tops off
at the beach don't you if you go to a
free you didn't know this all French
beaches the women take their tops off
not when I'm there cuz they they see me
looking is this how you met you went to
a beach and you were like oh she's
smoking
literally how long you guys been
together two years two years oh it's
recent um what what do you you was it a
big turn on that she was French don't
lie of course it [__] was this is
every man's dream a French woman that's
true that's true I I live in France you
live in France okay frch and then but
then you're are you from here I'm from
Atlanta you're from Atlanta okay cool
yeah oh from from the states that's cool
what what what attracted you to
him that's a good
question I'm sorry to break up your
relationship right
now his accent his accent when he speak
French really oh when he speaks French
oh so you speak it in like a prop at
Georgia accent basically yeah you're
like bour
[Music]
Miss jimel
Cletus a
away do bagett civil
play
[Music]
I'm so glad you guys are here this is
this would been terribly boring if you
weren't
wow it's it's mad to me to think that
youd find an at Lantern accent sexy um
so my my gorgeous georan what do you do
I uh represent photographers you
represent
photographers yeah she hates that job
over there in France that's the coolest
thing you can do right photography bit
try hard but being the person that's
like I'd take
10% good that that's cool that's very
cool a nurse and a photographer
representa I didn't know it was a
job is it
easy uh not really but not really it's a
pleasure it's a
pleasure I [__] hate you
now my jobs and pleasure this is [__]
hard work this I got a chat of Pricks
like you and make it hilarious I mean
I'm glad because this this conversation
went on longer than I thought it would
because usually you speak to a French
person and they're just like buff and
walk
away that's what you you you call the
English the the roast beef don't you
roast beef that's what they call us
because we eat roast beef is that why
yeah when you see an Indian person what'
you call
them
disgraceful disgusting and I didn't get
to chat with the Australians whereabouts
in Australia Sydney Sydney that's
[__] the most boring bit
it is it is you can't get into bars
after 1:00 a.m. um are you still living
there over here on the visit no I'll
live here now you live here now but you
keep the accent cuz it gets the [__]
don't
it they can't tell you and me apart you
know that like our voices everyone
thinks I'm Australian they think you're
do they think you're British South
African kiwi South African and kiwi
that's terrible isn't it people think
you South African how [__] dare
you oh my gosh wow um so you live here
what do you miss about
Australia that's the answer of someone
who does not Miss
Australia mate jellyfish at my ass every
morning [__] utterly [__] and I don't
live near the ocean they just squir ch
my God an Australian who hates Australia
a French nurse an atlantan photographer
representa um what's what's your name
Australian friend Jonathan Jonathan did
you spell it with an H definitely not
definitely not what j o n a t a
n there's no h in your name
Jonathan yeah I asked you to spell your
name with an
H
Jonathan Australians mate they're dumb
as [__] they know they can't their
letters were all upside down is it they
don't know H I thought you meant why I
was
confused I'm sorry Jonathan let me let
me make it up to you let me make it up
to you you um Val let's do this let's
let's have some fun so you you you
you're French obviously the French don't
know who I am I'm I'm a very famous
rapper in the UK and didn't make it to
Australia apparently I haven't made it
to America none of you know that either
but I I love to celebrate people like
yourselves with a little freestyle rap
that's rap that's made up about you so
let's uh let's do
this you just met buddies making the
mistake faking out the rapper on stage
there's no h in my name I be Jonathan
man no
just the end's just the A's yes I
succeed it's confusing alphabet get long
26 letters but I get it wrong I come
from Sydney you kidding me there with
the opera house over here made the noise
with my mouth like a horse like aie as
[__] I went over there a bit and then
I'm like n it's I be leaving off to the
USA it's where people from Europe come
to play they like we we I love the
Smokey air coming over here I'm in yeah
yeah just me that's you know I'm the
nurse if you get injured like y you go
to the hospital emergency room I just do
the accent I know I assume it's very
racist but don't disagree with me as an
English man think I'm kiwi South African
as well come from down there but a
French people lady with a nice hair and
defend is that a logo on the side you
don't even know you're just eyes wide
like I never saw the British man rap
before if you've got an injury to your
cor I said you in there walk down like I
like this I want to poke that pupil in
the iris ah you know I'm going to do it
I want to touch that vious fluid all of
the humor there on the Dome I know the
little words I look it up at home hey
you got
l i could do a little French when I'm 12
years old when I'm on the beach I hope
that it's cold so when they take their
bikinis off just a little I can see them
poke out there is he nipple I see a
French lady I adore you next to me a guy
from Georgia he's like seriously
masturbating they're so French he's just
waiting he comes from Atlanta the man to
be he's like okay let's go in buddy I
will be a guy walking and I'm getting
all of the ladies D SAR Co he L us so
crazy what do I do I know for sure I
take pictures I like photographers so
just Poe for me I'll make you wet I can
see you smoking there pulling on the
cigarette all the ladies go crazy it's
what they want to be nurses from the age
so early get into pom that's a fire
truck oh my God I know the words like
what's the [__] well there we go that's
a r I never say sorry give it up for
Georgian French and also the
Aussies you guys are lovely my name CHR
Turner thank you very much w